au-delà de ça l'europe et les chiffres
qui ont été citées par votre collègue
tout à l'heure le monde et le seul
compte le seul continent qui en plus
exporte ses deux seuls continents du
monde libre qui a une vraie stratégie
vaccinale est une vraie diplomatie
vaccinale pas pour aller faire du
chantage à tel ou tel pays mais pour
dire c'est un engagement international
qui est le nôtre et donc faut être très
clair nous sommes face à une guerre
mondiale d'un nouveau genre face
notamment aux attaques aux velléités de
déstabilisation russe chinoise
d'influencé par le vaccin
face à cela si nous voulons tenir nous
devons être souverain